Hey, this is really funny.
We have a voicemail number two one nine two.
David P and a Trump voter was not pleased
with one of our videos from last week that
went viral because I was in a different location
last week and he didn't like the size of my
microphone.
Take a listen to this.
Stumble across a show.
You were commenting on Donald Trump and.
The Hannity show, so on, so forth.
I think it's pretty weak.
It just sounds so weak.
Man put a put a picture on the wall from your
parents bedroom.
They're pretty drab and you've got a big giant
mark of a sale.
Who are you, man?
You know, we keep going.
Keep going.
Well, we'll just follow the money as you guys
lose the election again.
See you later.
All right.
It's funny, when people call in, they take
the time.
They've clearly watched enough to issue a
very specific critique.
They call in to tell me how unimportant and
and lame everything I'm doing is.
And their criticism is the size of my microphone
and the fact that I didn't have the place
I was broadcasting from last week sufficiently
decorated to their standard, you know, the
way you feel when I got a weak criticism.
That's what it sounds like to me.
But I love it.
I love it.
We had 200 new voicemails over the weekend
still going through them and a lot of action,
a lot of action.
Make sure to subscribe to us on YouTube.
We are racing to one million YouTube subscribers.
Make sure that you get our daily audio podcast
on any platform which you prefer.
Whether it's Spotify, Pandora, Google Play
I tunes.
I heart radio.
What else is there stitcher anyway.
We've also got a great bonus show coming up
for you today and I invite you to grab a membership
at join Pacman dot com to get instant access
to today's bonus